yeah I can hear you
no one's getting pregnant yes I know
condoms are not hundred percent
effective yes I know he's supposed to
roll it all the way down the shaft I
gotta go
no I was talking to my mom
morning everyone
and run and welcome to your first day of
law school baby just friends man you are
one heartbeat away from looking at her
differently oh this is Australian rules
football huh I guess oh my god that guy
just jumped off the other guy's face any
chain from International House having a
fight yo I will move when I'm goddamn
ready to move it not one second earlier
I reckon you've stopped moving right now
champ oh yeah backyard that is hilarious
I'm actually not doing a character and
I'm just talking you fully pops
I'm moderately pumped
[Music]
you